بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم
الشعب السوداني العظيم
اخاطبكم اليوم بصفه المواطن السوداني الذي
يشفق على بلاده واهلها اخاطبكم وبلادنا
تواجه خطر التفكك واقول ان الرصاصه حين
تنفلت من السلاح لن تميز بين المعتدي وغير
المعتدي والضحايا هم السودانيون رساله
الاولى للفريق هو العبد الفتاح البرهان
وقاده الجيش السوداني وللفريق اول محمد
حمدان دقلو وغاده الدعم السريع يجب ان
يتوقف الرصاص فورا ويجب ان يحكم صوت العقل
فالخساره ستكون من نصيب الجميع ولا يوجد
منتصر على جثث شعبي رساله ثانيه للشعب
السوداني بان يزداد تماسكا وان يكون تلاحم
مكونات المجتمع وخطاب رفض الاحتراب هو
السعيد وان لا يتم السماح لصوت اذكى الحرب
بالسيطره
رساله الثالثه للمجتمع الاقليمي والدولي
ومحبي السلام العالمي بان يقوموا بواجبهم
في الحل وتهدئه الاطراف المتقاتله فالحرب
في السودان تعني الحرب في الاقليم ولا
يزال الحل السلمي ممكنا حفظ الله السودان
وشعب السودان
لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار والبرامج
والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات والتقارير
الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في قناتنا
على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب وتفعيل
جرس التنبيهات